blake shelton spills details on his new
duet with girlfriend Gwen Stefani it's a
good of a song as I've ever written in
my life
the internet nearly exploded on Tuesday
after Gwen Stefani tweeted this the
artwork and track listing for Blake
Shelton's new album if I'm honest look
closely track number nine is a duet
between the couple called go ahead and
break my heart
of course et had to get details on the
collab from Shelton himself here's what
he told us on Thursday well people don't
know about looking at that is that we
actually wrote the song together she and
I which is very personal for us both
because you know we obviously have this
bond that is remarkable but the fact
that we wrote a song together
I don't co write that much because I'm
very insecure about it I guess I don't
know why I'm and when doesn't you know
she's kind of got her circle of people
that she writes with but for us to reach
out to each other as writers was may
never happen again who knows but this
song I hesitate to brag on it too much
but I really think that it's good of a
song as I've ever written in my life how
are they gonna sound are your are you
changing exchanging verses yes I mean
you know I mean people are gonna hear it
and they'll make everything it's a it's
a full-blown do it this is this is a
50-50 performance